well students and staff at marionette
Earl Elementary School in Spring Valley
surprised one of their neighbors with
very special delivery collecting canned
goods to donate to Christ the King
Church's Pantry which many students
families rely on photojournalist Henry
takai was there as the school teamed up
to give back
we're gonna start loading it over onto
the car it's really important for our
community you know because we talk about
the service we talk about gratitude we
talk about giving back we're going to my
class first our class had over what 600
items we do have a handful of families
that do use that food bank at Christ the
King Catholic Church which is right
around the corner from our school
that makes me feel great because that
makes me feel like everyone is just
coming together and helping each other
and helping other families that don't
have enough so they can enjoy the
holidays with their family I'll get the
cans right here we show our thankfulness
and our gratitude and that's a way that
we can give back as a school and also to
show those families that we support them
if you want you can put some cans in
here I'm happy that like I'm in class
but I'm happy to do like the entire
video so we learned teamwork we got the
team of three sometimes my family will
be in like the best situation so they
will be like depending on their last
savings for life and I don't want anyone
else to feel like that it's like a huge
amount and I was like really surprised
that that my class donated a lot to help
the community especially people out
there probably don't have like enough
food or they just need something so when
we just all help together we can just
help those people that can't that don't
have enough so they can enjoy their
holidays with their families last year
we collected a little little over 1 000
and that was a record this year we did
1600. this is a big box of cans what is
that oh a Ramen and cookie dough a
double chocolate I thought it was cookie
though probably get another card this is
so wonderful it goes so good this is
amazing I mean just just seeing all the
Outreach of people giving it's just a
beautiful thing we appreciate everyone
that has helped us out in the community
our kids get to take ownership it's just
so heartwarming especially during the
holidays